ah
[Music]
it's the 20th anniversary of the Selena
movie now as a young girl growing up
with latina roots I remember the first
time I saw Selena I was completely
floored
finally a pop star I could identify with
she was bicultural she had curves she
quickly became my favorite artist
[Music]
Selina's life was taken in 1995 when she
was just 23 years old she had this
beautiful personality and she had this
amazing talent and combining all that
together I think that that's why we're
still talking about her and it's like
all over again and it's a new generation
embracing her I came to Corpus Christi
Texas where the memory of selena
quintanilla is still very much alive
from the selena memorial statue to her
gravesite to the Selena museum i sat
down with Selena's sister Suzette and
her father Abraham in their very own
recording studio to commemorate the
film's 20th anniversary and pay homage
to Selena's life and legacy they mourned
in Corpus Christi Texas today Selena's
family her friends and her fans said
farewell to the young woman who meant so
much to all of them when she was gunned
down Friday allegedly by her fan club
president Selena was one of the biggest
stars of the spanish-language music
scene Selena passed in 1995 and the
movie came out in 1997 that's a pretty
quick turnaround why did you guys decide
to do this so close to her passing I
wanted the world to know about my kids
my daughter just to make sure that
Selena was portrayed in the right light
in the right way and making sure that
everything was based on on our life you
know the true way I entertained tonight
I'm Jennifer Lopez and you're on the set
of Selena welcome I'll be playing if you
haven't figured it out Selena you lived
with Jennifer Lopez while she was
preparing for this role what was that
experience like what did you guys do day
in and day out together we basically
just hung out to prepare you know I did
spend time with the family with Selena's
family she asks a lot of questions how
was is I how does she do this and we
watched videos together I guess really
just trying to vibe you know our family
not just who Selena was as a person but
I think us as a whole the first time you
saw Jennifer in hair and makeup what was
your reaction Wow she gave me chills
when I saw her because I was with him
when she walked out I literally like
first blood second I thought it was my
sister I mean the way she came out and
when she came down the stairs she kind
of like pushed her dress down the way my
sis
Derwood and it was she just looked
amazing
[Music]
[Applause]
there are so many scenes in this film
that are just so timeless and so iconic
but as a viewer I'm always wondering did
that actually happen the washing machine
seems is that something that your mom
your wife actually taught Selina
actually no okay what was true is that
we would go as a family down by the
water and we would you know hang out
there and we've talked and just be a
family basically and hang out by that -
the water that is true the line anything
for Selena's anything for Selena's
anything for Selena Lena the nest this
is what happened the driver kept
insisting that he could pull the bus out
and so finally out to him you know what
if you wanna try go forward and I think
it was about the fourth jerk is when
they ripped the bumper off and
everything like the movie they picked it
up put in the back to their car he said
he was gonna hang it up in his garage
with a sign that says Salinas that's
exactly like the movie were you
genuinely shocked the first time you saw
her on stage wearing a bustier yes of
course I'm a typical Mexican father but
it's the same thing as when I first saw
my daughter's we'll make up as they go
take that thing over right now
and a week later but your wife really
did help Selena make those yeah all the
singers are doing it's a style that word
bras yes Madonna Janet Jackson Paula
Abdul please you helped me make it
you helped awaken she always was very
classy about it it was nothing you know
vulgar I don't think that she ever
portrayed it to be you know showy thwart
with class always Selena and Kris
starting to date their relationship is a
big part of the movie talk to me about
how you found out about it is you in him
it's over
you can't tell us what to do I can tell
you anything I want to tell you you
don't think I know who you are you have
to understand my point of view how I see
things I didn't know Kris that well what
if he was a much of type I machista you
know there has been incident like they
they get married and say well you're not
gonna say no more and all the work all
the sacrifice that we're done will go
down you were very sensitive about that
scene the elopement scene in the film
because you didn't want little girls
watching it and getting any ideas I read
it and I said I want this off I want you
to check this out I said well Selena has
a lot of young girls as fans and I don't
want them to think that that's the right
thing to do I feel bad you know that I
was over strict too strict you know that
I put her in that situation where she
done that
[Music]
welcome to her family the decision to
include her passing in the film why did
you decide to do that we had to put that
in the movie because it was a true
happening you know she was killed we
didn't go into details but we did show
what happened to her Tejano superstar
selena quintanilla perez has been shot
allegedly by Yolanda Saldivar I think it
was done tastefully it's definitely a
hard thing to watch I remember my son I
would never let him watch the ending and
I hear that a lot from a lot of parents
that they don't let their child watch
the ending because they truly believe
that Celine is still here it's very hard
for us to even now to watch
[Music]
the only time I saw the ending was after
the movie was finished and we were in it
in one of the theaters at Warner
Brothers and all the Warner Brothers
people everybody was there the whole
crew that done the movie I saw the whole
ending and let me tell you it was very
emotional because everybody was crying
the first time I actually saw it
complete was the actual um premiere I
just kind of closed my eyes and try to
zone out and it's very difficult and it
brings back there's happiness clearly
and in memories but there's also you
know ultimately the fact that she's not
with us anymore you would program
emotionally and spiritually to accept
that the older folks go first but when
your child goes first it's a different
kind of pain I know how difficult it is
for my parents and I'm a mom now so
early on when she passed away I heard a
lot of people told would tell me like
you know time heals your heart timing
your heart and I I it was like I
couldn't understand that and it's not so
much that time comes your heart it's
more that time helps you deal with what
has been put in front of you your heart
will never heal there's this emptiness
should I say that's in the heart it
doesn't get any easier it's just you
just learned how to deal with it arm the
way where I was raised is knowing that
one day you know she'll be resurrected
and we'll see her again in my mind she's
still alive because you're getting
involved with all her things and you
know doing things for her everyday that
sometimes I forget that she's not here
with us anymore so in a sort of way it's
hard to explain that in my mind she's
alive make me cried that whoa is there
anger clearly yeah there's anger I mean
you cannot let that take over who you
are and what's in your heart we do not
speak of the person that really that
took her life we do not give focus to
that person at all it's all about Selena
in our heart if you had the opportunity
to talk to her one more time what would
you say
I would just hug her I wouldn't let her
go
[Music]
how do you want her to be remembered as
a given person sweet personality she was
always happy that's exactly how people
see her she's being remembered the way
she needs to be remembered
[Music]